[Music]
that's weird
I just noticed our drummer James warm
worth is gone that's crazy
Jimmy where is worm he just kind of
wandered off on his own somewhere I
don't know we wandered off you don't
know what he what does that mean he
wandered off guys I think he went to go
check out the old abandoned mine good
acting he abandoned mine the abandoned
mine how you do it that's a really
dangerous place I told every band member
never ever ever go near the abandoned
mine oh my god
kind of monster are you Welsh it's awful
I'm just have to assume now that worm is
dead well I mean we could send the
warner brothers cave rescue no no no
that would cost money money we don't
have we need a drummer now oh I can play
the drums
[Applause]
it's Max Weinberg
[Applause]
and Bruce Springsteen's E Street man
could you feeling tonight
[Applause]
he's gonna save the day
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
that's great max max Matt stop you
forgot well how we do this I still have
to say who's on the show tonight yeah
that part max you have to do that was
Springsteen all right ladies lemon what
a show tonight star the hit CBS series
Two and a Half Men Ashton Kutcher's on
the show
from Breaking Bad in the new film but
listen up Philip Christian Ritter's here
[Applause]
they just back is on the show
and we got Max Weinberg
we have so much more show coming up
we'll take a break we'll be right back
gentlemen
[Applause]
you